-I want to talk about the fact
that you obviously
had a longstanding relationship
with Trump's children.
And you mention in the book
that in the early days
of his campaign,
they would come to you and
ask him to get out of the race.
They also thought that his
rhetoric early on was racist.
Now, it does seem like they were
not repulsed on a moral level.
They were more worried about how
it would hurt the Trump brands,
the clothing brands.
What do you --
What have you observed
from their sort of journey
from being against his rhetoric
to now seeming to be very
full-throated supporters of his?
-It's really a complete 180.
When they first came to me,
the three --
Don, Ivanka, and Eric
came to me.
This was post the initial launch
of the campaign
when he made the statements
about Mexicans.
The very first reaction
by Univision was,
"We're pulling out
from the Trump Doral,"
and it was costing
the Trump organization,
between Doral and other
properties that they have,
it was costing them
tens of millions of dollars.
And the kids came to me,
and they stated,
"Look, you know, you got
to get Dad to stop this.
This is --
We're gonna be out of business.
Very soon you'll be the CEO
of this company,"
and they were gonna change the
name to the Rump Organization.
-Now, I do want to ask this
question of you right now --
-But it is interesting
if you look at it.
Don Jr. has now become
the spokesperson
for the Second Amendment.
And that's also,
I believe, included.
Trump hates guns.
Right?
And Trump hated the fact that
Don and Eric went to Zimbabwe
and that they killed
a whole slew of animals.
Could not understand how stupid
that they could be
to allow those photos
to end up on the Internet.
That, "You know, you guys think
that you're big tough guys
with a $10,000 gun
that I ended up paying for,
shooting, you know, an animal
while you're sitting there."
Many of us had to go there
and explain to Mr. Trump
that they had licenses for it,
that they did it the proper way.
They weren't illegally
doing anything
and that all of the meat
was actually provided
to villages
that survived off of that.
He didn't care.
It didn't make a difference.
He hates guns.
And it's just interesting
that now Don Jr.,
who was really considered
the one child
who had the worst judgment
of any of his children,
somehow managed to be
front and center,
specifically with the NRA
and talking Trump.
I mean,
it's truly an amazing thing.
It's something that he's wanted
his whole life,
acknowledgement from his father.
-It does also amaze me
that maybe where Trump
is most concerned about legality
is in big-game hunting.
-Yeah.
-Michael, obviously,
you're aware of this,
that a lot of people --
You say it's important
to write a book like this,
because to understand
the badness of Donald Trump,
you have to hear directly
from the bad guys
who worked for him and did
the bad things for him.
You're admitting
to serving that role.
Yet there are people questioning
why you should be sort of hailed
as an anti-Trump hero now
after everything you have done.
Like, what do you say to people
who question the way
you're being perceived now?
-So, first of all, I've never
asked anybody to call me a hero,
to the same extent I never asked
anybody to call me the villain.
I have to make amends
to my wife, my daughter, my son,
and to this country.
And as I stated once
to George Stephanopoulos
several years ago,
my loyalty is to my family
and to this country.
And it took me getting --
basically losing everything.
I talk about this
in the epilogue
that I'm broke and I'm broken.
And it took this sort of kick
to really push me
into acknowledging the things
that I did
and the loss of my moral compass
for a man who lacks
a moral compass on his own.
Why I fell into the cult
and how I fell into the cult,
I really can't
describe it adequately,
other than to say the 38%
of this country, his base,
including members of Congress,
are doing exactly
the same thing that I did.
And I'm trying to say to them,
from one member of the cult
to another,
open up your eyes
and acknowledge
that Trump doesn't care
about you,
he doesn't care about
your family,
he doesn't care about anything
other than winning this election
and, in essence,
becoming an autocrat,
which is what he wants to be.
-Also in the book,
you sort of admit to personally
and sort of rabidly
pushing the birtherism,
um, you know, "theory,"
for lack of a better term.
As we're having this sort of
national reckoning of race,
I imagine it must be painful to
acknowledge the role you served
in putting a racist
in the White House.
-Well, yes.
And one of the things
I tried to do when I created
the National Diversity Coalition
for Trump
was really to open up his eyes
and understand
that America is not white.
America is a multiracial,
multiethnic country.
We're the melting pot.
And he really needs
to understand that.
And so
I created this organization
that really exploded in size.
And we had everybody from,
you know, Jews to Christians
to Muslims, black, white, brown.
It encompassed everybody.
And my hope was that,
by seeing his crowd,
which is predominantly white,
and it is to this day,
that he would understand that if
you want to win the election,
you need to seek out
the minority vote.
You need to understand
that America -- right? --
is not white and that, you know,
they are an important
voting bloc.
They're important
to this country.
And I failed in that.
I failed miserably.
-I was surprised to read, but
also appreciated the honesty,
that you do still
have affection for
and care for President Trump.
-Yeah, it's -- it's hard.
I guess the only way
to describe it is
the same way you have a parent
that is somewhat abusive to you,
and you still care about them.
But at least I recognize the
person that I'm dealing with.
And again, all I'm just trying
to do is to make amends
and to allow the book
to serve as a basis
for people to understand --
this is the man that wants you
to vote for him
and to pull the lever
on his behalf come Election Day.
And I'm giving you all of
the inside information
that you need in order
to make the determination
whether this man
is really who you think
is best for you
and best for this country.
-Well, Michael, I do wish you
luck in your next chapter.
And I want to read
just a quote from the book.
It's really
a beautiful piece of prose.
And I hope
if there's anything
that people take away
from the book, it's this.
"Trump was fresh from the shower
and hadn't done his hair yet..."
-[ Laughs ]
-"...as it was still air-drying.
When his hair wasn't done,
his strands of dyed golden hair
reached below his shoulders,
along the right side of his head
and on his back,
like a balding Allman brother
or strung-out old '60s hippy."
Really, truly, beautiful prose.
-Seth, thank you very much
for picking
that part of the book out.
-And I do recommend, everybody,
when you buy the book,
just go right to
"Flip flop flap,"
because that is an incredible --
incredible explanation
of what's going on up there.
Thank you so much
for being here, Michael.